[Music]
on this Tuesday night developments in
the investigation into foreign meddling
allegations an MP who sources alleges
connected to Chinese government
interference speaks out just very little
I can do to defend myself plus the prime
minister's Chief of Staff agrees to
testify and the man who'll decide
whether there's a public inquiry is
given a deadline inflation is falling
but food costs won't stop climbing while
you're being advised to check your
receipts Nova scotia's remedy to retain
nurses we need you the financial
incentive the province is offering and a
stirring show of support we just wanted
to come down here and show our respect
the poignant tribute to two Edmonton
Police constables
[Music]
Donna Friesen good evening and thanks
for joining us we begin in Ottawa and a
little more clarity on how the probe
into allegations of election
interference is going to unfold
Canadians will know by May 23rd whether
Republican query will be called that is
the date spelled out in the terms of
reference given to former Governor
General David Johnston appointed by the
prime minister to be the so-called
special rapporteur as well the prime
minister's Chief of Staff Katie Telford
will testify before a committee as the
opposition has demanded our chief
political correspondent David Aiken has
all the details David
yes thanks John and of course all the
opposition parties they're unanimous
they want a public inquiry but prime
minister Justin Trudeau again today
promised he will do whatever former
Governor General David Johnson tells him
to do on the issue of holding a public
inquiry into allegations of foreign
election interference and as you
mentioned Johnson will make that
recommendation in two months May the
23rd but Johnson has a second task
report on the ways that federal agencies
can better work together to identify and
combat foreign interference the deadline
for that task is not until October the
31st and David the opposition has been
pushing for days to get Katie Telford
the prime minister's Chief of Staff to
appear as a witness today it was
announced she will appear at a committee
why do they want to hear from her
the opposition believes that you know
Telford is the prime minister's chief of
staff and is his longest serving and
most trusted political advisor and
therefore she has crucial information
about what the Prime Minister was told
about election interference and when he
was told about it the opposition is
trying to prove that Trudeau turned a
blind eye to warnings by security
officials about alleged interference by
China because the Liberals stood to
benefit from that interference
ever the Prime Minister was completely
asleep at the switch or he allowed it to
happen because it benefited the liberal
party which is it now for their part the
PM and other liberals say that's
nonsense
the conservatives are trying to Gin up
the toxicity and partisanship by making
political Theory theater out of it
and Don I think it's very important to
note as well that right now there is no
evidence from any agency that this
alleged interference changed any
election outcome now as for Telford she
is expected to testify sometime in
mid-april okay David Aiken thanks
the liberal MP who National Security
sources have told Global News was part
of an alleged foreign interference
Network spoke to reporters in Ottawa
today Han dong according to sources was
one of at least 11 Toronto area
candidates allegedly supported by the
Chinese government in the 2019 election
sources also told global news that cesis
believes dong is a winning affiliate in
China's election interference networks
Mackenzie gray heard what he had to say
Mackenzie
spoke with reporters for over 20 minutes
on the hill today where he denied the
Chinese Consulate in Toronto allegedly
helped him win his 2019 nomination
meeting
can you categorically say that they did
not help you yes I can just say that you
know to my to my knowledge I was not
offered I was not told I was not
informed nor would I accept any help
from a foreign country whether during my
nomination or my election
and I asked him directly about the key
allegations from our reporting Donna
that the Chinese consult in Toronto
busted seniors and international
students to vote for him in his 2019
nomination meeting here's what he said
did you see any irregularities at the
nomination meeting that would suggest
that any of that my campaign offered
transportations to seniors not just
Chinese seniors and the bus involved in
the transportation is properly expensed
and reported and that's on public record
it was it was resurrectly International
so I don't really don't know who's
International who's not International
it's not my job to check if they're
International students or not
International students
but how dong knows the Chinese Communist
Party didn't interfere in the election
or his nomination meeting is unclear he
said he spoke with some of his campaign
team members who denied the allegations
but one person dong hasn't talked to is
the prime minister or his office and he
hasn't asked them for any information in
a bid to try and clear his name
prime minister's office to clarify this
to clear the air
because it's unverified Anonymous
allegation I first I gotta find out
whether it's a leak from CSUS or not
dong has written to thesis to try and
figure out some of that information out
he's asked them about the allegations
and to know if the lease came from the
spy agency they've acknowledged his
letter but one thing they haven't done
is contact dong himself about the
alleged interference
I've never received a phone call from
Jesus I've never made aware that if
there is investigation whether by ceases
rsmp or elections Canada pertain to my
nomination or my election
Don says that he supports the current
measures the Liberals have taken to
investigate foreign interference Donna
but one thing he wouldn't say is whether
or not he supports the idea of a public
inquiry okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa
tonight thanks there is a promise from
the federal government to spend more
money on defense 1.4 billion dollars
will go towards revitalizing the
training center of the Canadian Armed
Forces Special Operations unit the money
seen as a long overdue investment in the
Aging facilities at their base Canada
has long been under pressure from NATO
allies to increase defense spending
Toria Israel looks at this commitment
and how it's being received
Joint Task Force 2 is Canada's Elite
counter-terrorism unit ready for
immediate action but nothing has been
immediate when it comes to upgrading
their training base we need to continue
to do whatever is necessary in this
changing world the Department of
National Defense announced a
long-awaited overhaul
1.4 billion dollars on upgrading the
Dwyer Hill base in Ottawa construction
will start in may it's expected to take
a decade and create 2 000 jobs we see
the increasing need to make investments
of this sort
that need is huge given Canada's aging
cf-18s and frigates and roughly 10 000
vacant positions and it starts becoming
a very complicated picture because of
the the the decade of neglect
in 2007 then Prime Minister Stephen
Harper expropriated land wanting to move
the base from the capital to CFB Trenton
about three hours south the Liberals
scrapped that plan in 2020. now they're
unveiling an overhaul just days before
U.S President Joe Biden arrives in
Ottawa of course it's political of
course the timing is everything in that
context military experts say it's
becoming harder for our allies to call
on US Canada routinely misses its NATO
spending targets and is under mounting
pressure to ramp up air defense in the
face of rising Global threats the world
around us is uh taken a very significant
turn in a very dark Direction with what
we're seeing happening in Eastern Europe
with what's going on in indo-pacific
with a China Deputy Prime Minister
Christia Freeland gave a pre-budget
speech Monday but did not mention the
Canadian military once Canada's really
not been investing enough in its in its
own capabilities to take care of you
know protecting Canada
capabilities only becoming more critical
in an uncertain World tariya isri Global
News Ottawa
there is New Hope tonight for Canadians
shelling out big money to make ends meet
inflation cooled in February the
sharpest deceleration since April of
2020 the Consumer Price Index was 5.2
percent last month down from 5.9 percent
in January shelter costs rent and
mortgages increased at a slower rate for
the third consecutive month the price of
groceries is still rising up 10.6
percent in February as Ann gabiola
reports it's more important than ever to
make sure you're paying the right price
overall inflation eased in February but
food prices increased more than 10
percent year over year and a new poll by
the agri-food analytics lab suggests
Canadians might be leaving money on the
table when they shop if you're walking
around the grocery store looking for
bargains it may just be an illusion if
you're not checking your receipt as you
exit the store three quarters of
respondents reported the price of an
item on their receipt being different
from the Shelf in the past year more
than a third didn't get a daily discount
applied 31 percent had a cashier scan
too many items 16 percent had the wrong
code applied and nine percent were taxed
on a non-taxable item the fix is simple
check your receipts but many don't
bother I never felt any need to to to
check it
yeah I think more in a in a restaurant
we more it might be more inclined to to
check it as they're scanning sometimes
they scan too much and then I'll say you
know something but not after I usually
don't even take a receipt after if I am
coming for groceries for like a
particular discount or or anything that
I'm interested I will probably have
receipt to see if the discount are
applied properly here's something you
may not know most Grocers are part of
the retail Council of Canada's code of
conduct which states that if there's a
mistake on your receipt and you paid for
an item that was incorrectly priced the
grocer owes you that item for free if
it's under ten dollars to check the
receipt you would need to know what the
advertised price is
so I mean that's that's that could get
quite complex the report doesn't specify
which grocery chains make the most
mistakes but researchers say the average
person can save 50 to 70 dollars a year
by catching errors in the face of food
inflation which has been at double
digits for seven months in a row every
little bit helps with overall inflation
seeing the biggest deceleration since
April 2020 most economists now expect
another interest rate pause from the
Bank of Canada at its next announcement
on April 12th Donna okay and gaviola in
Toronto thanks after announcing his
imminent arrest Donald Trump has yet to
be indicted in a Manhattan courtroom the
former U.S president has tried to Rally
his supporters calling them on them to
protest at the courthouse Jackson prosco
is there Jackson no sign of trump or of
criminal charges today what's the deal
well Donna Donald Trump's claims about
his arrest were rooted in media reports
about the preparations underway here in
New York for the very likely possibility
of his arrest or indictment that being
said as you mentioned he remains a free
man tonight the grand jury though does
reconvene tomorrow and it's not clear
what business exactly they'll be
undertaking in the case one thing is
clear both the D.A and grand jury are
believed to be in the final stages of
their work investigating those alleged
hush money payments made to a former
adult film star and so the question
Donna is what does the timeline look
like going forward if Trump is indicted
he'll have to fly himself to New York
and turn himself in for arrest he would
likely be processed like any other
prisoner fingerprinted and photographed
and Donna Trump's calls for protests
have largely gone unheeded last night a
rally of his supporters outside the core
Courthouse only Drew about a dozen
people there were more reporters than
actual protesters here
all right Jackson prosco and Mennonite
thanks
Finance president
she says he signed an agreement with his
rounder part Vladimir Putin entering
what he calls a new era of cooperation
foreign
State visit to Moscow is happening days
after the international criminal court
issued an arrest warrant for Putin
alleging war crimes in Ukraine the two
leaders called for responsible dialogue
to resolve the Ukraine crisis the
Chinese leader said Beijing has a
neutral position on Ukraine and is
Guided by the principles of the U.N and
called for dialogue Putin has praised
parts of beijing's 12-point plan to
de-escalate the war but blames Ukraine
and the West for rejecting peace talks
losing trust ahead the embarrassing
scathing report about the UK's largest
police force
a 15-year-old appeared in a Nova Scotia
court today charged with two counts of
attempted murder related to a stabbing
at a high school yesterday Halifax
police were called to Charles P Allen
High School shortly after 9 A.M Monday
investigators allege the teenager who is
a student at the school stabbed two
staff members police say those two
people remain in the hospital in serious
but stable condition a bail hearing for
the accused is scheduled for Thursday
in the UK a year-long review of London's
Metropolitan Police Force has reached a
damning conclusion that it is Rife with
a boys club culture and the force could
be dismantled if it does not improve the
report was commissioned after a serving
police officer raped and murdered a
woman in 2021. it found the med is
institutionally racist misogynist and
homophobic and has lost much of the
Public's trust it lists the Litany of
failures and concludes that London no
longer has a functioning neighborhood
policing service our Europe bureau chief
Crystal commencing on the report and the
reaction
a nearly 200 year old institution as
recognizable as the city itself is
losing its luster it's ghastly isn't it
you sit down and read that report and it
generates a whole series of emotions it
generates sort of sort of anger
frustration embarrassment embarrassment
for the more than 30 thousand officers
who wear the uniform along with
discrimination a review found prevailing
misogynistic attitudes and a flawed
approach to investigating rape and sex
crimes failures that mostly impact women
and girls the kidnap rape and murder of
Sarah everard by a serving that officer
was the Catalyst for the Louise Casey
report she says changes should have
happened back then I find it
extraordinary that in policing and in
the Met place
that wasn't their moment of like a plane
falling out of the sky
for a year-long review included
first-hand accounts from citizens and
those inside the met in one case a sick
officer had his beard cut a Muslim
officer found bacon in his boots and 12
percent of women in the Met reported
being harassed or attacked at work
politicians at all levels and of all
Stripes say the public trust has been
damaged and that this report is a
warning for more than just the mass
discrimination must be tackled in all
its forms and I welcome sir Mark's
commitment to do so
I will be holding a metropolitan police
and the mayor of London to account by
measuring their progress I'm concerned
that the home secretary's statement is
dangerously complacent
astonishingly there is no new action set
out in her response simply words saying
that the Met must change the mayor says
he has confidence in the Met
commissioner to turn around the service
despite Casey describing it as defensive
and resistant to change a report notes
if sufficient progress isn't made this
time radical actions might be required
such as breaking up the institution
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Nova scotia's retention prescription
coming up the province's plan to stop
nurses from quitting
across this country there's a shortage
of nurses from burnout to strains on
Mental Health Advocates say more needs
to be done not just to recruit nurses to
the field but retain them Nova Scotia
has become the latest Province to try to
address the problem offering big bonuses
to help keep nurses on the job Alicia
drows has the details
Nova scotia's Health Care system has
been handcuffed by a shortage of nurses
for years with about 1600 province-wide
vacancies right now my message to every
nurse in the province is simple we need
you Premier Tim Houston says recruitment
is a priority with new job offers for
every nursing grad over five years one
pillar of its plan now a massive
investment in retention Nova Scotia is
offering nurses up to twenty thousand
dollars in bonuses to keep them in the
province's public health system
full-time nurses get ten thousand
dollars and double that an additional 10
000 is being offered to those who sign a
two-year deal to stay ten thousand plus
another ten thousand that's
significant money because when you go
from Province to Province you're giving
up your benefits you're giving up your
pension plan so it's not as simple as
I'm just going to go there and make X
more dollars retention bonuses for
Frontline health care workers are
becoming more common Ontario promises
five thousand dollars for every nurse
there in Quebec it's up to eighteen
thousand dollars across the country
provinces are competing for highly
skilled Talent much of it burnt out by
years of pandemic stress so those have
provided a something to think about for
so many of those nurses that previously
were I'm out of here but money alone is
in everything Nova scotia's nurses union
says the biggest reason nurses are
leaving comes down to better balance
prioritizing casual work like travel
nurse positions it's that flexibility
that you weren't that is not possible
when you when you hold a regular
position
nurses are applauding the new policies
and they're expected to help in the
short term but the next generation of
nurses May seek more holistic approaches
to better serve them so they can do the
same for their patients Alicia drows
Global News Halifax
paying respect next a public tribute to
two Fallen police constables in Edmonton
in Edmonton the bodies of two police
constables killed last week while
responding to a call about a domestic
dispute removed from the medical
examiner's office to a funeral home and
they were not alone lining the route
were fellow officers and members of the
public there to pay tribute to the young
men who died in the line of duty Heather
urik's West reports
with a loss so fresh and difficult to
comprehend
members of Edmonton's Police Service
joined heartbroken residence to line
city streets as the bodies of constable
Brett Ryan and Travis Jordan were driven
solemnly by people in this EPs and all
First Responders in the city put their
lives on the line for us every day
at least I could spend the least I could
do is spend a couple minutes to pay my
respects the two young officers just 30
and 35 years old had been responding to
a domestic violence call last week they
had just arrived at an apartment
building when police say a teenage boy
armed with a gun shot both officers
several times before injuring his mother
and then killing himself it was actually
heartbreaking devastating and there's
there's so many questions that my
friends and I are asking ourselves like
how did the 16 year old get a gun
straight to the Canadian flags the
bodies of the two officers were taken
from Edmonton's medical examiner's
office to a funeral home in the city the
families of each officer in two city
buses trailing behind
Corporal Travis Jordan originally hails
from Cold Brook Nova Scotia Brett Ryan
was the first time father to be their
loss felt so deeply by not only those
who knew them best but a city of
strangers as well we just wanted to come
down here and show our respect the
officers will be honored with full
regimental funerals next week but the
city is showing its support for the EPS
right now every day the blue ribbons is
a visual cue for people to stop and
think and I love seeing them out as much
as I hate seeing them out a show of
support amidst immeasurable grief
Heather urich's West Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday we leave you tonight with more
moments from that procession in Edmonton
people paying tribute to officers who
are doing their job protecting the
community thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]